hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and
[Music]
i'm just checking in on you
just checking in to see how you're doing
do i sound
a little excited
do i sound like a man who said something
that was gonna happen and then it did
i got powers man
i say [ __ ] and it happens man
if you don't believe me
go back and listen to my podcast last
week what the [ __ ] did i say
what did i say
i said
it's beginning to look a lot like 2001.
who is this mac jones
and our coach is billy b and he's
working on the d and all the colts fans
are gonna cry i called it
i said bill belichick was gonna go out
there to buffalo
and he was gonna coach a [ __ ]
masterpiece
which he did
okay
beethoven couldn't write a [ __ ] game
plan like that you know why because he's
a musician
other than that
other than that that man i guarantee you
had a a decent weather game plan that
would have beat the buffalo bills that
night
and all of a sudden they were 50 mile
per hour wins and these four poor
[ __ ] kickers are going out there you
see that bar stool sports [ __ ] video
guys trying to kick like a 35 yarder
it's up it's good it's blown away
started hovering like a heliocopter
there
bill belichick
is a [ __ ]
genius
the man is a [ __ ] genius and i know
there's there's the [ __ ] [ __ ] out
there right
going like go
jones always threw the ball three times
that's the only amount of times he had
to throw it
all right josh allen was throwing the
ball all over the [ __ ] field it's
almost like he didn't want the ball in
his hands i think he was a little scared
um
i'm [ __ ] with you it was a great game
you know i love the light show that they
put on on niagara falls buffalo you know
doing it up
smashing tables lighting up
water
you know
eating spaghettios out of a can i mean
how much more down-to-earth do you guys
got to be
it's so hard to hate buffalo bill fans
unless you're amongst them wearing a
patriots hat then yeah then it's kind of
easy
to kind of wish the whole [ __ ] suv
went right over the [ __ ] fall
right over it
landed nose first on the [ __ ] rocks
and you guys just sit there breathing
your last bit of air inverted as you
sink down
inside we'll we'll give you in that
we'll give you a ford explorer
uh
yeah man we just [ __ ] ran the ball
and ran the ball and ran the ball and
ran the ball and that was it
that was it and our offensive line was
better than that d-line
for that night
and now we're up two games
to zip
not two games none we're up two games on
them so who knows who knows we could
shut the bed next week you don't i'm not
gonna be i'm not gonna go versey on you
right now
and start high-stepping during the
[ __ ] regular season like my good
buddy does there
all right um
i actually thought that the bad weather
was gonna
be a disadvantage for us for some reason
i just felt like
you know i thought belichick was gonna
come up with this game plan mac jones
was gonna be ridiculously accurate the
way he has been all year but for some
reason he's not getting credit
specifically from buffalo bills fans
you know hey we're not scared tom
brady's not coming off that bus yeah
well bill belichick was
and he came off that bus and he ate your
[ __ ] wings
and he took your hearts and he went home
and that's it
all right fred smirless wasn't there to
save your ass
neither was bruce armstrong or jim kelly
all right
buffalo's e street band
no i'm [ __ ] with you um anything can
happen we got to play them again
i'm just psyched that i [ __ ] i just knew
we were going to win that game
i mean did you put any money up bill
yeah i bet a little bit
i took the pats and the under
how do you like that how do you like
them apples isn't that what we're
supposed to say there in boston ever
since goodwill hunting came out how do
you like them apples
there's no apples left just an empty
barrel
and all your hopes and dreams get in
that barrel and go right over the falls
into [ __ ] who owns who owns niagara
falls
buffalo and like what
hamilton ontario
is it a sovereign state
is it part of ottawa does the family
that makes crown royal do they own part
of it i have no [ __ ] idea
um
anyway
it was a great game for when i saw it i
was going out i had the kids at night
you know and it's just a major battle
major battle when i'm shutting off a
kid's show
to watch what's known in my house is
daddy tv
you know then i have to be like watching
the game while entertaining them so i
gotta play like how many times do you
think he can run around the couch before
i catch you
you know so i got to do that so i get
some cardio in i get some cardio and i
gotta tell you something you know oh
billy eggnog tits as you guys been
calling me they come it's coming down
it's coming down
um
all right guys well remember i was
telling you there was those [ __ ] cats
uh
if you're a member of uh
i don't know if you're an animal lover
you might not want to listen to this
especially during the holidays
everybody's like oh jesus what happened
to the [ __ ] cats
well there was these two adorable
kittens that were just [ __ ] living
outside and they weren't they were sort
of like you know eight-year-old
kid cats they were like that size they
weren't kittens
they were like [ __ ] big they were out
you know
they were on their own
okay
and uh they were hanging around
and then they disappeared and then they
came back and they were over here for
like three days and we were trying to
get him into like a cage or whatever
these [ __ ] things would just you
couldn't get anywhere near
the hiss they growled i mean these
[ __ ] things were like little bobcats
right
feral i believe they call them so they
left and i had heard a noise and i was
thinking the worst you know
coyote got him or a [ __ ] raccoon or
some [ __ ]
and uh you're giving up hope
you know
two weeks had gone by
hadn't seen him two and a half weeks or
something like that and the other day i
was making breakfast and all of a sudden
i hear my wife go oh my god she goes
bill bill look look they're back they're
back and they're right at the back door
cute as ever
doing all that [ __ ] we're like holy [ __ ]
right so [ __ ] you know gave him some
salmon some anchovies right
they're not too into the anchovies but
you know fed them and [ __ ] and i'm
trying to coax them you know trying to
get to know them and they're just like
you know
not afraid of me but not letting me come
you know near enough to to
i don't know pet him or whatever and
gain their trust
so anyway
um
whatever so now they're back in our
lives
all right so i drive my daughter to
school
and i'm on my way up i'm gonna go fly a
helicopter right gonna solo it
so i keep the confidence up i know what
the [ __ ] i'm doing and as i go up there
all of a sudden my wife texts me she
says call me
so i call her and i pick up the phone
and she is sobbing
absolutely sobbing and i said what's the
matter what's the matter
she said one of the cats got hit by a
car and is dead
she goes it's laying in the road all
mushed up it's disgusting
we got the there's people doing some
work on the house i had him shovel it up
so our daughter won't see it she was
absolutely sobbing she just goes it's
just so i just can't believe
something could be there and then a
second later it's just gone it's just
dead
and i'm on my way to solo a helicopter
so she's just like hey i hope i didn't
mess up your day
so um
i was she was bummed out i was
ridiculously bummed we both were so
[ __ ] sad
because uh even with a little
interaction we fell in love with those
little [ __ ] cats right
so
anyway
i go out
i fly around you know go up to like
magic mountain
having a good time up there come back
land and everything and uh end up coming
back so now it's like well now we got to
save the other one gotta make sure we
get somehow so just so happen we had a
friend over that's a cat person she had
a cage
um i don't know what the [ __ ] i was
doing
probably doing a podcast i don't know
what i get a text message from my wife
saying that her friend caught the cat
it's in the cage she knows where to take
it so i'm like great
i don't know
i didn't know that yet she goes so now
the cat is in a cage in my house and i'm
like jesus christ my wife is allergic my
daughter's gonna fall in love with the
cat and then what the [ __ ] gonna
happen
all right somebody's getting up crying
or somebody's getting up sneezing
so i'm like oh boy
so i end up getting in the house turns
out a friend knows what to do so i start
to bring the cat out
you know in the cage or whatever
and it's sort of you know getting a
little [ __ ]
antsy or whatever and then when i get
outside
it starts freaking the [ __ ] out
i mean
all over the cage jumping up coming up
and i got to like set it down so it
doesn't claw my fingers i know this
thing doesn't have a shot so i started
dragging the cage and the bottom plastic
thing moved i didn't realize it so my
friend had like these gloves and she
goes all right let me just pick it up
with the gloves you picked it up and it
was just a little bit of a hole and that
[ __ ] thing took off
and i was just like all right that's it
forget it
it's over all right we lost that cat to
the streets that that [ __ ] thing is
like this thing turned into a [ __ ]
bobcat the second we got out it was
scared it didn't trust us we put it in a
k i don't think we'll ever see the thing
again because as much as it was getting
free salmon
you know it also got put into it it's
you know cat guantanamo
so we haven't seen the thing since but i
can guarantee you this that thing is not
gonna have a [ __ ] problem other than
cars surviving neither one of them did
and that's what i was thinking i didn't
see them
i saw one and then then all of a sudden
three weeks later i saw two then we
didn't see him for three weeks and then
they came back and they never looked
hungry
so they were killing something out there
and i'm sure there was other people
feeding them in the [ __ ] neighborhood
but uh i don't have any worries
about that cat anymore that [ __ ]
thing uh
i don't know what that thing it it has
earned its stripes
jesus christ i can't even tell you how
much that thing [ __ ] wigged out when
i brought that thing out of the goddamn
house
i was like easy buddy easy okay easy
kitty easy k this thing's like wow
jumping up you know hissing at me doing
all of this [ __ ] like i will [ __ ]
murder you freckles if you don't get me
out of this [ __ ] cage right now
and um
i don't know once a cat is feral can you
like make the thing like a like a
regular cat
you know
something just you know chilling out
sitting on your [ __ ] head as you
watch colombo
i don't know i don't know what the deal
is with that thing but uh
i feel horrible it was the [ __ ] worst
goddamn day
when the other one got squashed out in
the [ __ ] road um
and then i thought for half a second i
was like oh my god did i do it
because it happened so i like looked
under my car i made sure i didn't have
any blood on my tires or anything like
that so i had nothing
um
but there you go
so that's the end of it and now
if the cat comes back i'm not feeding it
because that thing is [ __ ]
that thing i i respect that thing now
it's just i i mean i loved it before i
was like oh you need my help you don't
need my help
it's got [ __ ] four freddy krueger
hands and it is ready to use them plus
its mouth and it growls this thing's
like
all right and you know what's funny is
there's gonna be a cat person out there
going you know what you should have done
you know what you go [ __ ] do it okay
cause i don't know what i should do and
it's not my job to be a [ __ ] expert
and everything all i know is i did what
i thought i should do and i almost got
[ __ ] clawed up by this [ __ ] thing
so
you know
if you want to feel bad for something
feel bad for the birds in this [ __ ]
neighborhood because that thing is good
it's kind of going there's going to be
some bird cops like with [ __ ] little
tacks and yarn trying to figure out the
kill zone that they need to stay out of
with that thing around
uh much respect all right so
i'm doing this podcast tuesday night not
not necessarily because i want to gloat
about the patriots victory
um i'm not gloating about it i'm just
[ __ ] psyched that i was right
um
i actually i just literally got my
booster shot
about an hour ago
so
you know
it gives me the option if i get a little
sick
i don't have to do the podcast and then
i also have the options if i don't get
sick which i don't think i'm gonna get
too sick cause i didn't get too sick the
other two times
um
i can kind of play it off like oh you
know i got the booster man i could just
[ __ ] chill out in my bed
you okay i'm whispering this like if my
wife couldn't hear this you know like
she doesn't have the ability to listen
to a podcast
um
yeah i went in and i got the [ __ ] done
it was [ __ ] hilarious
i get the boosted shot and i'm sitting
there and then also you just hear this
down the aisle you see this guy go [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and i was just like
all right you know
everybody just sort of stands around
it's really amazing what you can do in
public and the amount of people that
just aren't going to do [ __ ]
you know you always think i can't do
something like that or i'm going to get
thrown out of the [ __ ] store
immediately everybody just sort of
stirred around like okay
is that the end of it is that a
frustrated parent that's what i was
thinking and then
i just hear it getting louder and louder
the dude had a radio i forget the song
it was funny because it was one of those
inspirational songs
he had that on
and i see a security guard walking him
out
and he's saying to the security guard
yeah i bet your mother's proud i bet
she's real proud of you and i was
thinking
well yeah i'm sure she is
what is she proud of you shoving [ __ ]
toothpaste down the front of your
sweatpants you [ __ ] [ __ ]
um
but you know we let him go we just
says get out of here whatever the [ __ ]
it is you're doing
so he must have caught him
stealing some
shave or some [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know let's uh sir you mind
putting that back [ __ ] [ __ ]
he's just walking him out i bet you're
pressing i got a little show
i got a little show
um so anyway
um
i ain't doing [ __ ] for the next 24 hours
another upside of this i'm supposed to
drink water
they feel a little queasy take a little
tylenol
um
so whatever we'll see what happens i
just have my blood work done i still
have the [ __ ] anybody so
i think i'll be pretty good let's do
some of the reads here for
for the week here oh by the way i got
another like
you know
major like
i don't know i want to i want to buy a
[ __ ] dirt bike just because i learned
how to ride a motorcycle i don't want to
forget how to do it and if i've ever in
a movie my character has to drive one
down the street i don't have to have the
stuntman do it you know
it's one of those [ __ ] things right
so i just want to get a dirt bike
you know
i got a place where i can keep it
there's just a big [ __ ] area where i
can drive it
but i just know i'm gonna wipe out at
some point i'm gonna [ __ ] my leg up and
it's gonna be right before i have acting
work or i have to go do a show
but um
i was looking them up that [ __ ] some of
those things are [ __ ] expensive
you know i always heard that ktm is the
best i look those [ __ ] things up
those things are ridiculous
ktm
dirt bike let's see what these things
yeah yeah those things let's see what
let's see what a classic old
honda goes for
you know although i you know motogp i
always root for the ducatis
not motorcycle honda
killed you [ __ ] finally that
same fly from the other [ __ ] day
mosquito dead
dead done see ya
honda
dirt
bike see what these things go for
you want a two-stroke you want to throw
a stroke
i will take the old man four stroke it's
cleaner for the environment and then
also you know it's not
super fast
well there's one for 900 bucks
on amazon
that can't be real
are you kidding me
signature series full system stainless
steel muffler
there is no [ __ ] way you can get a
dirt bike for nine hundred dollars on
[ __ ]
wait a second
the yoshimura
why is there always numbers two two five
eight four zero r five two zero rs nine
t signature series full system stainless
steel muffler oh it's a muffler
there you go you gotta read the whole
thing there's no [ __ ] way
it's like jesus christ amazon's just
giving them away
all right
here we go
off-road
honda
okay we'll go trail i don't need
competition
what am i gonna be on [ __ ] espn
they should have that the dads of dirt
bikes
every trail all right there's the little
one for the kid
here we go
yeah they're like 10 grand
a 450 though all right so a 125 is 3 600
bucks
i got it my ego has to get me i have to
get a 250 at least
that's like five grand five grand you
got five grand never that
16 candles i heard the grill alone cost
five grand
um
i'd love to teach my kids how to ride
but then to be afraid that they'd
actually get a motorcycle
um
all right let me see this [ __ ] thing
you guys literally listen to me build my
[ __ ] dirt bike that my wife won't let
me get what am i doing let's get to the
advertising all right indochino
all right personal style can define you
as a person and help you express
yourself
and the end of the year is a great time
to take a look at your closet and decide
what's working and what's not indochino
can get your closet where you want it to
be before the new year starts or you can
gift a wardrobe upgrade to someone you
care about with an indochino gift card
offers completely custom fitted suits
shirts casual wear and more at
surprisingly affordable prices get a
wardrobe personalized to your style and
taste without spending a fortune every
piece is made to your exact measurements
and you can customize every detail
choose everything about your suit
including the fabric lapel monogram and
statement linings
you can create a suit that fits you and
your style perfectly give yourself a
custom closet revamp with indo cheeto
or the gift of great style with an
indochino gift card get 50 off any
purchase of 3.99
or more by using promo code burr b-u-r-r
at
indochino.com that's 50 off a purchase
of 3.99
or more at ind wait i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o
dot com
promo code burr
i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o
dot com
promo code bird p-u-r-r oh look who it
is everybody it's roman
hello roman
uh roman you know when the moment for
intimacy arrives you need to be ready
roman ready
you need to have a toga wrapped around
the shaft of your [ __ ]
uh whether you've been in a relationship
for years or just getting started
having the confidence
that comes from preparation means you're
free to enjoy the moment when the moment
comes
even though you are far i just pictured
your dick standing side the side of the
stage
waiting for its cue
um you can [ __ ] me now that's you go on
you're on you're on even though you are
far from ordinary the truth is that e.d
erectile dysfunction is really common in
fact 52 of guys aged 40 to 70. i love
70.
yeah of course 70. jesus christ you're
happy if you're getting up up the
[ __ ] couch
experience some of uh some form of
erectile dysfunction uh go to
getroman.com now to speak to a u.s
licensed health care professional about
your erectile dysfunction and get 15 off
your first month of treatment e.d is
more common than most people think in
fact 52 percent of men between the ages
of 40 and 70 will experience some form
of
erectile dysfunction
roman's system is completely
confidential and totally destroyed
doesn't work man they're not going to do
that for you no big logos or labels on
packages a u.s licensed healthcare
professional will work with you to find
the best treatment plan if medication is
appropriate it ships to you free with
two-day shipping uh getting started is
simple just go to
getroman.com and complete an online
visit take care of your ed without
leaving your home uh complete an online
visit today to connect with a u.s
licensed healthcare professional and
take care of it go to
getroman.com today and if you're
prescribed get 15 off your first month
of ed treatment make sure you're ready
to have confidence and control this fall
roman
ready
you want the emperor going thumbs up a
thumbs down get roman
all right oh look who it is everybody
it's solo stove
for all you loners out there we got a
stove for you
solo stove kidding there's nothing quite
like the feeling of gathering around a
warm fire on a cool evening
and a smokeless fire pit from solo stove
makes your outdoor moments even more
memorable
yeah if you just around a fire i think
you'll remember is smelling all [ __ ]
smokey
because instead of having to constantly
dodge campfire fumes you can sit back
relax
when it's time to relax one stove comes
clear
fire after fire if you've got solo stove
there are no fumes you [ __ ] [ __ ] um
and actually enjoy the fire with solo
stoves holiday sale you can get a great
deal on a solo stove fire pit solo stove
fire pits are brilliantly engineered
main with premium grade 304 stainless
steel whatever the [ __ ] that is sounds
impressive to me and a 360 degree
airflow system that maximizes efficiency
while minimizing smoke it's like a
vaporizer
except there's no weed man
there's just s'mores so you [ __ ] vape
your weed and then you go out and you
make some s'mores right there there's
your whole [ __ ] evening easy to light
with a few bits of stutter your fire is
blazing in minutes perfectly portable
take solo stove with you on camping
trips and more i'd take it to a tailgate
i'd stick it right under those tables
those [ __ ] bills fans jump on just to
add to it
add a little wwf to the action
um lyft uh one of those crazy bastards
is going to do it uh let the gift giving
begin if anybody does that
no no i don't want to be connected to it
don't say anything
shop solo stoves holiday sale for huge
sitewide savings now through the end of
the year and get 10 off with promo code
burr b-u-r-r plus a lifetime warranty
and free 30-day returns get an extra 10
off holiday deals at solostove.com
promo code burr and lastly but certainly
not leastly because you know what
everybody's special
liquid iv or liquid four as i read it
i've watched too many super bowl
highlights who won super bowl four the
kansas city chiefs
64 toss power track
hank stram giggling like the [ __ ]
joker
vikings running around like a [ __ ]
what do they say chinese fire drill
which you can't say anymore you'd have
to say running around like a fire drill
with a group of people of any sort of
race that didn't know what was going on
liquid iv everybody cooler weather makes
it easier to miss signs of dehydration
like overheating or perspiration
which means it's even more important to
keep your body properly hydrated
i just realized how stupid chinese fire
drill even that didn't even make sense
that was just straight up [ __ ] racism
like who the [ __ ] knows what your fire
drill looks like over there well they're
not us so they're confused you get it
jokes means we're smarter yeah but it's
not based on anything
all right flu season is in full swing uh
proper hydration and vitamins can help
support a strong immune system making
hydration a priority helps us feel
healthier on a day-to-day basis and
fuels us to be our br highest potential
one stick of liquid iv in 16 ounces of
water hydrates faster and more
efficiently than water alone not only
that but the product tastes oh you know
what i gotta ask chinese people
listening to this i gotta ask you guys
questions at the end of this not only
that but the product tastes great with
flavors like watermelon
strawberry and lemon and lime are you
gonna be enjoying a few drinks now that
the that the holidays are approaching
this is what you need liquid iv hydrates
faster and more efficiently than water
alone
contains five essential vitamins more
vitamin c than an orange and more
potassium
and has as much potassium as a banana
healthier than sugary sports drinks no
artificial flavors of preservatives and
less sugar than an apple made with clean
ingredients no gmo vegan and free of
gluten dairy and soy
remember soy was supposed to be good
jesus christ we read them wrong huh grab
your favorite liquid iv flavors
nationwide at walmart
or you can get 25 off when you go to
liquidive.com and use the code bird
b-u-r-r check out this 25 off anything
you order when you get better hydration
today using promo code burr burr at
liquid iv.com
all right chinese peoples you know what
i got a letter from a couple you guys
from beijing mainland china i've got a
few from i want to know this like we got
that all we used to have that expression
like a chinese fire drill just total you
know
racist thing what jokes do you have
about americans about white people
specifically come on i want to hear them
i want you to write in what you guys say
there's got to be some jokes about how
we don't [ __ ] make anything over here
anymore there's got to be some jokes
about uh there's always jokes about
[ __ ] you know
you know vaginas or horizontal or
whatever come on i want to hear i'm
gonna hear it sammy send me your
ignorance this is what we'll exchange
during the holidays oh it's beginning to
look a lot like 2001
um
the new england patriots
are nine and four
they started off two and four
how do you start six games in the season
i don't know
but it works for this voice
we are now the number one seed in the
afc
for the playoffs does that mean anything
it means we get home if the season ended
it ended today we would have home
field
remember everybody all excited when tom
brady left
and they act like bill belichick left
too they act like bob kraft left
all right
we still got we we still got a [ __ ]
run in us
where's my two
not like everybody says
no i'm i'm uh
i am excited cause i gotta be honest
with you i
was like numb when tom brady left all of
last season i rooted for cam newton and
i lied to myself that i was okay with
the fact that the dude left
all right and then this year it's
settled in like [ __ ] he's gone
he's gone oh wow
and
it's like all right
we got this kid mac jones
bill belichick is excited about him he's
letting him start that's a good i that's
a that's a good sign
and hung in it but i never would have
thought in a million years as great as
bill belichick is
and i i would never think that we would
be where we are right now so i am very
excited much to the chagrin of all the
other [ __ ] sports fans
in the nfl out there they all you know
for the most part you guys [ __ ] hate
us but i am a happy patriots fan so [ __ ]
all of you
um
we're coming back and we got as good a
shot as anybody man i'm getting too
excited
i just thought it was gonna be like a
three-year build
you know with mac jones to get to where
we are right now
all right
that's it who knows a month from now we
could drop four in a row and that could
be the end of our [ __ ] season i don't
know i have no idea
all right whatever
i got my christmas shopping done which
isn't real isn't i i got all the the
people in my life done but then my
nieces and nephews i gotta [ __ ]
handle that [ __ ]
and get him like
you know i'll tell you what's underrated
getting a gift coming home and wrapping
it
okay and just you put it to bed
you put this [ __ ] to bed or you let it
pile up one way or the other
and then you wrap them half boozed you
know
any kids start thinking about drunk
elves or whatever they still believe in
all of that [ __ ]
um
i don't know
so
i have a few i have a few to add here
and uh i just got my third microchip
shot into me
according to the uh the people who
aren't sheeple
um that's what they think
maybe it was a third of a microchip a
third of a microchip and now the third
one
you know
isn't three is three a magic number is
that a satanic number
let me just check this out
now that i've signed myself over to the
devil let's see what let's see what we
got here
is
three an evil number all right let's see
what we have here
evil numbers oh look at this
[Music]
evil numbers
little witchy woman for you
very little
okay the first evil numbers are what is
this okay in number theory an evil
number is a non-negative integer
that has
an even number of ones in its binary
expansion oh is that what it is
oh my god integer i'm gonna break out in
a [ __ ] rash i haven't heard that word
since i've
integer to me means hopeless um these
numbers give the position
of the zero values in its in the
thumors sequence
and for this reason they have also been
called the
thumors set
non-negative integers that are not evil
are called odious numbers
i'm going to see what the thumb sequence
is
hey guys remember that through more
sequence if you're gonna go to a bar in
cambridge near harvard there's some [ __ ]
you could [ __ ]
in mathematics the thumb or sequence
or
pro head through more sequence is the
binary what is binary
i thought that was a sexuality
uh a bit stream
also known as a binary sequence it's a
buy stream is a sequence of bytes
then i gotta look up bytes and it just
never ends it's like a [ __ ] hummel
um [ __ ] it i don't know what it means um
the binary secret an infinite sequence
of zeros and ones
obtained by starting with zero and
successively appending
the boolean
okay [ __ ] this all right i'll just tell
you what the evil numbers are
the first evil numbers are 0
6 9 10
12 15
17 18 20 23 24 27 20. that's like
[ __ ] all of them 30 33 34 36 39
all right
i'm gonna go back and i'm gonna name
athletes that wore all these numbers
let's see if i can go up to 39.
um
zero
uh that would be uh jason tatum three
babe ruth
five
joe dimaggio
six
who the [ __ ] wore six
i'm trying to think yankees here because
all those single numbers are gone at
this point
i have no idea who oh bill russell
[ __ ] idiot i am
uh number nine
oh
teddy ball game ted williams number 10
fran tarkington number 12 roger starback
number 15
[Music]
number 17 uh jim hart
number 18
was i always get these confused that was
peyton manning
number 20 billy sims
23 michael jordan
24 i don't know 27 mike krushelnisky
29 j miller
number i can't do no 24 terry o'reilly
what am i out of my [ __ ] mind
number 30.
chris nylon
33 larry bird
34. uh
was that kevin mchale
36 jerome bettis 39 sam bam cunningham
go [ __ ] yourselves i have no life all
right that's it everybody
um we have coming up next
we have a bonus uh not a bonus we have a
uh we have the bet mgm
where me and uh paul versi if you ever
want to learn how to live life
you got to listen to paul verzi nobody
understands what is important in life
the way paul versey does
i am married because of that guy
he's the one that talked me off the
[ __ ] ledge i was a jumper and he got
me to go back in the window now i have a
great life thanks to him
so um listen to this clip we'll do our
nfl picks for week
15 i think 14 15. i don't know what it
is at this point uh so check it out i
hope you enjoy it all right everybody
what's up we are back with our week 14
nfl preview and as you guys know we have
teamed up here at anything better with
bet mgm and it's been amazing the most
reliable lines we're having such a good
time uh using the bet mgm lines make all
of our picks with them okay and we'll
have special offers if you make all of
your picks with them we'll have special
offers for our listeners each week and
bet mgm has a big announcement this week
louisiana
we've got some exciting news for you
louisiana home lsu tigers
[Music]
bet mgm is finally coming to louisiana
okay
uh while sports betting isn't live quite
yet there okay you could sign up early
and receive two hundred dollars in free
bets just for signing up just use bonus
code burr b-u-r-r to sign up bonus code
okay when you sign up no deposit is
required that's right sign up if you are
uh if you're in louisiana use bonus code
bur burr for 200 in free bets and get
started when sports betting is live if
you're in any other state bet mgm is
live you can use bonus code bur and
you'll get 200
free after placing your first 10 bet
here's how it works you download the bet
mgm app and sign up using bonus code bur
that's b-u-r-r you'll receive 200
okay so yes so if you place your first
10 money line bet on nf any nfl game
you'll receive 200 in free bets
immediately after placing your bet
regardless of the outcome which is
fantastic and louisiana get ready
because that is coming for you as well
guys just download the bet mgm app use
bonus code burr you're getting money to
have a good time with us now
let's get into the nfl preview right
when paulie thought he was gaining some
traction everybody paulie was looking at
his games he's gone off three and one
and sure enough
bill was right there next to me going
three and one i gained [ __ ] zero i am
running out of time folks at one point
did you think you were gated on me i had
the thursday game i was 1-0 that's true
you did that one was the one where i was
like oh dude he's definitely gonna go at
least two and two
uh i don't know dude i thought last week
was gonna be bad dude we spanked the
book last week we went [ __ ] combined six
and two people
six tell you right now if you want
winners
yo uh watch this week we'll go 018.
[Music]
you know what that's never happened if
that happens we gotta have a name for
that yeah we do
i am back to 500 i am 26 and 26 bill
continues to hold a three and a half
game lead at twenty nine twenty two and
one
and now we are precarious three and a
half game lead i have not felt good
about my picks in a month
um
but now we are on another week
uh and and i see the lines here bill
we're on actually it's an even week so i
believe that we are all caught up with
who goes first and i believe bill goes
first this week because it's week is it
week four all right i'll tell you who i
like i'm gonna take the seattle seahawks
at houston minus seven and a half i
think russell wilson is healthy
i think uh you know pete carroll's got
pride up there they got a lot of losses
they want to finish the season strong
houston at this point what are they what
are they they're playing for a [ __ ]
draft pick i say they go in there
and they kick the they kick the the pine
tar right out of them uh yeah they take
those trash cans the astros left are
laying around they put it over their
heads and they [ __ ] bang it with a
wooden spoon dude you went after that
game so fast i picked i picked against
the texans last week it was 31 nothing
oh man the texans have been a gift that
i did not take advantage of that's not
true though that's not true houston and
jacksonville are the two teams that you
think are a gift and then i don't know
where they [ __ ] you and they beat the
bills
they cover
all right well if there was gifts we'd
have a better [ __ ] record although
our record's pretty great against the
spread record's pretty good dude after
13 weeks come on dude if we were picking
the money line we'd have a network gig
right now we'd be sitting here wearing
[ __ ] sport coats
i'm taking the tennessee titans giving
eight and a half to the jacksonville
jaguars [ __ ] [ __ ] off of bye week
they're coming off a bye week uh i think
they're playing jacksonville come on
they're playing jacksonville they're
well come on man you just picked a team
that's playing the texans i'm mad you
took my pick it's a great pick
has nothing to do with you it has to do
with my emotions i'm sorry i stepped all
over you good paul no no no no i'm
taking the tennessee titans i love them
i love them home and i love them after a
bye week uh eight and a half's a lot of
points but i think they win that game by
at least 10.
all right i'm gonna take uh my arizona
cardinals oh you've been running
original rivalry i've been riding them
all year minus two and a half hosting
your los angeles ramps
oh that's a good game that's gonna be a
great game
i like them at home paul
i like at home rams are [ __ ] erratic
you know last week they [ __ ] had a
big win they beat the [ __ ] out of
somebody was it houston
was it houston who did they beat last
week they beat the [ __ ] out of somebody
so i think you know they're strutting
around they probably banged a couple of
celebrities when they got back to la you
know they're going to take their foot
off the gas a little bit before they
realize that kylo murray is going to
have them up by 10 points
all right well
i'm going to do something here i hope
i'm gonna do something here i'm not that
comfortable with but i think their
season's completely on the line
and the line indicates that that so
there's a desperation in this game i'm
taking the san francisco 49ers beating
joe burrow again
back-to-back weeks joe burrow's gonna
take an l
i think san francisco it's now or never
i'm taking jimmy g
and the san francisco 49ers getting a
point it's basically a pick em
uh i think it's the 49ers season so i'm
gonna take that
ooh i was thinking about taking
cincinnati i don't know uh but you know
what my next one i don't know about this
game
because they might be going to their
third string quarterback the new orleans
saints minus six and a half at the jets
is interesting to me
um
i don't know i think this is
[ __ ] it i'm gonna take the saints given
six and a half he's actually at five and
a half now it's only five and a half all
right five and a half beautiful i'll
take it at five and a half even better
all right which means a bunch of people
i think are thinking that that kid that
runs all over the field but this other
kid that they're
third string kid
sort of a drew brees six foot guy can
run around makes things happen he takes
pride in his accuracy i mean those are
the kinds of things paul that when
you're playing the jets in new york
you can get me more than five and a half
old freckles
limping paul limping over the finish
line i like when you go making money for
you
uh
i'm going i'm gonna ride this again dude
i'm taking they're hitting a stride
right now i'm taking to washington i'm
taking washington at home against boys
against the cowboys getting four
they have back-to-back wins they're in
the wild card hunt ron rivera's got
those team playing that kid heineken's
playing good team's got confidence and i
don't know
it's heineken
that's heineken
um i'm gonna take washington getting
four at home
i think paul what are the heineck keys
of the game behind the keys of the game
are keeping it close with the running
game and controlling the clock and i
think if dallas does win that game i
think they win by a field goal and i
sneak out a win by a point
all right i got a crazy one this week
paul oh boy and this might make
us come right down to the wire i'm
taking a chance on this one
i'm gonna take the buffalo bills getting
three
in tampa
if you weren't [ __ ] texting you'd be
like what i'm not texting i'm looking at
the games i would never be texting
during this i don't know i saw your
thumbs moving what are you getting
outside help you caught a [ __ ] man
i'm looking at the lifeline out there
paul you're getting desperate
mr high stepping in [ __ ] october i
took exception to that
uh
you really poked the bear when you said
that uh um
bill pl the bills plus three
they had a [ __ ] just a stupid loss
last week against the patriots as great
as that was a win masterpiece i mean
you're literally playing a game where
you kick a field goal and it's good and
it gets blown away i mean what the [ __ ]
are we talking about here i think
they're pissed um
i don't think the rest of tampa bay is
going to play up to tom brady's
standards
i think they're all the much no matter
how much tom yells at him i think
they're a little too [ __ ] satisfied
about last year
and the bills are like jesus christ are
we gonna [ __ ] let this city down
again i think they go down there and
they [ __ ] win the game outright
i'm sticking with
all right dude this isn't i i i don't
know
dude the fourth game this late in the
season is tough
i don't know man i love the packers
i love the packers but that's a lot of
points
and part of me is uh should i go head to
head with you and take the bucks but i
think the bills are desperate too
i don't know what you see like you you
sit there going like dude i'm [ __ ]
taking the packers put it in the bank i
mean they're they're playing the best in
the nfc
i know but they're playing uh they're
they got to win by two touchdowns
you said that i'm they're they're going
to the super bowl
you said put it you said put it in the
books it's done they're going to the
super bowl they're the first they're
playing the best football that's not a
[ __ ] insane pic
no no [ __ ] text to me last night like
he had inside information
no no
what do you mean
you said you put it in the books it's
already in the books they're the
favorite
i mean is anything in the books we don't
know if anything's i mean i don't know
you're saying put it in the books all of
a sudden i thought i was getting inside
information i was like wait a minute
they're [ __ ] crushing it wait but
aren't the tampa bay bucks number one in
the nfc at nine and three
oh are they i don't know i got kids and
what about
no
i don't even know
i couldn't even name the divisions right
now paul somebody told somebody said
something great last night they go how
come nobody's talking about the
cardinals going to the super bowl for
the nfc and that's another thing but i
don't know i'm i'm i just don't know
bill
i'm just not blown away by their coach
and as someone who hasn't played
organized football except for two weeks
in august and third grade like i have a
lot of concerns about as a stand-up
comedian
all right dude i'm i'm calling an
audible here man this is not good
dude do you realize how great it would
be if the packers go
because then like you'll have all
football fans and then you'll have
vaxxed versus unvaxed people also
watching the super bowl wanting the
vaccinated quarterback of the afc
to beat the unvex and vice versa i mean
the whole the whole [ __ ] country's
going to be watching i mean if people
are that [ __ ] if people are going to
turn it into that
we're talking about paul that's all
they've done with sports sports used to
be an escape now every week i'm [ __ ]
watching somebody with lyme disease
crawling across the 50-yard line to flip
a coin
just a reminder people are suffering
enjoy the game
i'm taking green bay
laying twelve well mercy putting his
dick on the table
i'm taking aaron rodgers and the packers
they're playing the bears and they need
home field they need home field
throughout the playoffs if they're going
to beat the bucks they're going to
[ __ ] lay it on them uh i think that
the quarterback is hurt for chicago
chicago so let's go they beat him by two
touchdowns there you go andrew dude he
owns the bears he said it himself on
national television
tampa and uh
tampa and green bear both and the top of
their division if i were you guys asking
yeah my who's who's the number one seed
though
uh who gives a [ __ ] it's the [ __ ]
regular the car is the cardinals they're
tenants are the number one seed i like
it that's right you just disrespected
him i heard kyla murray watches this
podcast i didn't hear that but i hope he
does so i hope he's feeling some type of
way about that pick you just slapped a
future mvp of the league
in the face paul
well listen in the face he's good but oh
uh don't tell me don't tell me don't
tell me don't tell me yes
america coming to america there you go
in uh when they were at the st john's
game yes in the face
um
all right bill you know what the time it
is
oh you know what time oh uh let the
monday not special
it's the monday night special with some
money for you
and uh this week it's the los angeles
rams at the arizona cardinals and the
line is two and a half by the way our
apologies not that we owe apologies but
what could we do with the last monday
night special when the wind is blowing
the patriots throw the ball a couple
times
the other team throws a ball a couple
times there was nothing to really i mean
by the way paul did i call that game or
did i call that game
you call that hey man you call that game
and not only that the first thing your
first instinct was what
under under
under
you know you know somebody actually
placed a bet it was ten dollars it was a
fifty dollars to win ten thousand and
what they did was they bet they put
together a parlay and it was all the
unders for receivers figuring it was
going to be you know not a lot of balls
put in the air so they took all the
unders for every receiver what they're
expected to get put 50 bucks and they
won 10 grand
wow awesome what a smart what a smart
andrew you really just kind of blew my i
knew who was going to win the game out
of the water i was all excited about
that then that guy comes along listen
this threads that needle
i came out and i hit a giant beach ball
that was coming at me and this guy
[ __ ]
turn around
all right what do you think good for him
man tyler murray running for 50
or 45.
kyla murray for as much as he runs is
not what people think see he is he
definitely rolls out he's like a even
faster doug flutie if he's watched doug
flutie play he ran a lot at the times
but he didn't like run down the field
so i know he does do that but he a lot
of times you know
not the tallest guy so he's just getting
away from the uh the trees so he can see
what's down the field so
50s a lot of yards
and i also think the ram the rams have a
good defense
um i like 45 more than i like 50.
you're not gonna win as much money but
you're gonna win
tyler murray to rush for 45 yards i love
mm-hmm
and then that uh that [ __ ] uh cooper
cup or whatever the [ __ ] his name is oh
my god that guy always he always has
like 9 000
that guy's catches
um
i'll be honest with you i don't know
okay how about this what about a sack
they got one of the best front fours out
there they got j.j watts they got uh
chandler jones jj watts out for the year
i wish i knew that before i bet arizona
this week
what happened to him no he's been hurt
yeah he's out man i think he's out um
about matthew stafford matthew
stafford's having a good year right he's
got odell now odell's got back-to-back
games with a touchdown he's got cool
he's having odell an advantage
seems to it seems that the last two
weeks he's been a choir boy catching
touchdowns but i think that's how those
guys are yeah they're in a new
relationship hey can i get the door for
you
sure i love that kind of movie too
yeah then he smacks the [ __ ] out of your
date nine
yeah you didn't put enough butter on the
popcorn
um
i like chandler jones to get a sack i
like kyler murray to get 45 yards and
then i like something for matthew
stafford i say matthew stafford throws
throws
so bill said cardinals two sacks we'll
go with that you want to go matthew
stafford throwing two or one
i don't want him to throw any i bet the
[ __ ] cardinals
all right so we'll go matthew steve well
he's got that cooper cup that son of a
gun runs all over he's like a water bug
out there paul he's gonna throw one so
let's go matthew stafford throws one the
cardinals get two sacks
what do you want the third one to be but
with kylo ren kyla murray is going to
run in for a touchdown there you go
all right everybody that is the end of
our week 14 um preview i hope you guys
enjoyed it and again please sign up to
bet mgm for all of their reliable lines
um by using bed mgm lines um
we can actually give you some money how
about that and louisiana they're coming
to you got exciting news for you bet mgm
is finally coming to louisiana
while sports betting isn't live yet you
could sign up early and receive 200 in
free bets just by uh signing up
use bonus code burr burr when you sign
up no deposit is required that's right
sign up if you're in louisiana use bonus
code burr for 200 and free bets and get
started uh when sports betting is alive
if you're in any other state bet mgm is
live you can use bonus code burr get 200
free after placing your first ten dollar
bet here's how it works you download the
bed mgm app you sign up using bonus code
bur b-u-r-r place your first bet 10
money line on any nfl game you'll
receive 200 bucks and free bets
immediately after placing your bet
regardless of the outcome you're getting
two hundred dollars if you pick if your
pick stinks it doesn't get better than
that guys so uh
join bet mgm use bonus code burr enjoy
it we use it we love it we're having a
great time most reliable lines out there
you guys know ben mgm you've been
looking at that lion your whole life
take care this is it we will see you
guys next week visit bet mgm.com for
terms and conditions 21 years of age or
older to wager arizona colorado d.c iowa
indianapolis louisiana michigan missouri
new jersey nevada pennsylvania tennessee
virginia west virginia wyoming
washington only all promotions are
subject to qualification and eligibility
requirements rewards issued as
non-withdrawable free bets or site
credit free bets expire in seven days
from issuance excludes michigan
disassociated persons please gamble
responsibly gambling problem call one
eight hundred next step in arizona
1-800-522-4700 colorado dc louisiana
nevada wyoming virginia
1-800-270-7117 for confidential help in
michigan 1-800 gambler in indianapolis
new jersey pennsylvania and west
virginia or 1-800 that's off in iowa
call or text the tennessee red line
800-889-9789 tennessee or call
1-888-777-9696
in missouri or 1-800 547-6133
for washington that's 1-800-547-6133
sports betting is void in georgia hawaii
ohio and utah and other states were
prohibited promotional offers not
available in nevada all righty there was
the little bet mg mgm that you said bet
mgm clip for the week
um now we're gonna have a little music
interlude here picked out by the uh
wonderful
beverly hills dwelling uh andrew
themless and uh after that we will have
a bonus episode of the thursday
afternoon just before friday monday
morning podcast from a thursday a little
while ago all right that's it
uh have a great weekend you [ __ ] and
i'll talk to you on monday
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday december 9th
2013. how you doing how are you how's
your weekend how's your christmas
shopping
oh my god there's so many people to buy
for there's not enough time what am i
gonna do you know what you're gonna do
just bake them a [ __ ] cake
all right you walk right up and you mush
it right in there [ __ ] [ __ ]
happy holidays
[ __ ] all you you know that's the only
reason why you like me you're gonna
judge me on my goddamn gifts well i got
a gift for you it's right there you got
frosting in your pubes all right who
else does that for you nobody
and now you know now you know who really
cares about you
um
sorry i'm in a grumpy [ __ ] mood i'm
having a great time over here still
still in europe i'm uh i'm in the
emerald isle
ireland i'm in dublin ireland tonight
hoyt toity too
uh just landed this morning i already
called the opium anthony guys to
announce the second annual patrice
o'neill comedy benefit
all the proceeds
uh goes to his uh wonderful family his
loving family and uh we're also going to
give some money
for um victims and strokes it's just a
great
great benefit um that we're doing again
this year because so many people wanted
to come last year we only did one show
so people still want to come out
and uh but also a bunch of other comics
were like what the [ __ ] bill how come
you didn't ask me to be on it and i was
like well listen you know
i tried i did my goddamn best all right
so we're doing it again this year and
i'm just gonna keep [ __ ] doing it
uh hopefully as long as we can
because that's what patrice was doing he
was taking care of his family so we're
his friends and we're stepping up and
god damn it why don't you help us step
up by buying a [ __ ] ticket well we
will build but first why don't you tell
us about all the wonderful talent that's
on the show well god damn it i'm gonna
all right we have the wonderful jimmy
norton nick depaolo dave attel colin
quinn dane cook talent
myself rich foss bonnie mcfarlane keith
robinson robert kelly big j olgerson and
harris stanton okay you think there's a
better show out there
well then god damn it you go to it but
if you don't
come on down tuesday february 18th
2014. tickets are on sale right now
we'll have the link if you follow me on
twitter
um i got that up there already
and uh it's for a wonderful wonderful
cause and um it's becoming this great
thing now or we're just going to be
celebrating um
just our great friend and how funny he
was and his unbelievable work
and it's now also becoming kind of like
a reunion thing it's it's really become
a great thing so we'd love you to come
down and share the experience with us
while raising money for a wonderful
cause there you go and um some of you
have bitched to me going like dude why
is it on a [ __ ] tuesday you know i
got school the next day i understand
that i apologize
but you know if you want a great lineup
of comedians
um
you know to do a benefit
tuesday is the night when the most guys
are in town most people have gigs on
saturday nights and that type of [ __ ]
um so most people are out of town
so tuesday night is is the night i
picked because
you know as much as you want to go to
this thing stand-up comics want to be on
the show because we all love the guys so
that's why it's tuesday night i know
it's a bit of a pain in the ass but hey
it's a goddamn charity
you're gonna [ __ ] about charity all the
comics are working for free
okay so go [ __ ] yourself one person who
complained about that that it annoyed me
so much that i felt like i needed to
address it
all right so here we are
now on to the podcast oh my god the
place is that bad and the thanks i've
ate
i can't remember if i if i just did this
on opium anthony but even if i told you
about it last week i need to warn you
guys
i went and i saw the sistine
chapel
and it is the sistine chapel i thought
it was the 16
as in one six and i was sitting there
with the lovely nia as we were standing
in [ __ ] line that wasn't even that
bad that bad because it was the winter
time
uh
and basically this is the deal when you
go in to the
the vatican i guess the the ass end of
the vatican
okay and i'm gonna i'm gonna really
sidestep the easy joke there
okay
with all due respect to all the victims
when you go into the anus of the vatican
you have two options when you go into
the sistine 15 chapel either go left you
go right
okay if you're wired like me go to the
right you'll go right into the sistine
chapel all right but if you're an
unlucky dumb [ __ ] like myself you go oh
right left right bucket i'm going left
and i went left
and uh you go through the whole vatican
um museum
and within there they have every
vestment every [ __ ] spatula
every light bulb every [ __ ]
priest ever used
and you're walking through it and it
just keeps saying sistine chapel sistine
even though i still thought it was 16
because i'm a [ __ ] idiot
right
so
and every other room the ceiling is
painted so you walk in you're like is
this it is is this
is this decision no no keep going keep
going
basically by the time you get through
all this [ __ ] you don't even care
anymore and then you walk in there and
it's ridiculously small
it's not nearly as big as they make it
look on tv don't they make it look like
it's
you know would like take up the whole
ceiling of your living room just that
one picture of god
sort of uh gingerly touching the other
guy's finger it isn't it's just this
little [ __ ] thing that you could
cut out of the ceiling and put under
your arm
bring it to all your friends house one
weekend
is that from this the 16 chapel dude
yeah it is
so uh and you know what's worse is once
you get in there and then you're looking
and you start going oh my god it's not
even that big but then you know what the
[ __ ] you know all the guards who are
standing there just sit there shushing
people shh
the whole time you're in there and
that's when the stand-up comic in me
slash control freak kicks in you're like
all right you know what [ __ ] you [ __ ]
this stupid picture and your silly
outfits
from 300 [ __ ] years ago all right you
got every goddamn thing in this museum
it's you got every
[ __ ] shoe
every gold plated whatever you got
everything about the catholic church in
here except for the rape murder and the
[ __ ] pedophilia
[Laughter]
i didn't have the balls to say that
because
they're their own country
they're a sovereign state as they say so
as much as i i wanted to say that aside
from whose can do i didn't have the
balls to say that or the wherewithal to
think of that in that moment when i was
being shushed
um
i didn't know what happens like what
happens if you say something like that
when you're on the vatican grounds do
they just
kick you back into italy
you know what i mean or do they take you
down into some dungeon
and basically treat you like they
treated a lot of little boys
i couldn't resist sorry um
great now a bunch of [ __ ] jesus
freaks are gonna
no if you're a jesus freak can you still
listen to this you're an [ __ ]
all right
you're an [ __ ] you know what you know
what i think anyways let's plow ahead so
so i i mentioned i said 16 chapel tania
what did i say to i said you know what
this [ __ ] line is so long
already forget about in the summertime
so you know we should do we should open
a bar across the street and go we should
call it the 17 chapel
you know
and she's looking at me like what are
you talking about
i'm like you know 16 chapel and across
street 17 chapel you know you you get
[ __ ] up
because your feet are swollen from
standing in the line for so goddamn long
she just sort of cocked her head she's
like bill you realize it's the sistine
chapel
you realize that
and i just smiled at her and then she
just started laughing at me just
realizing what a [ __ ] idiot
that she's decided to spend her life
with
[Laughter]
and i'd love to tell you guys that that
was just a joke that that's just a silly
[ __ ] anecdote it isn't it's a hundred
percent [ __ ] true
i kind of knew it was cysteine but it
just became 16 in my head
i have that same disease my dad has
where for john elway's entire career he
called him john onway
and you'd be like dad elway elway would
be like on uh what is it uh onway
anyways this this john onway i'm telling
you this guy he he can run he he
confessed that it's elway i i heard him
just let me finish let me finish this
guy
you know so i i think i inherited that
from him
i i don't i don't know if i don't hear
well
or i'm so wrapped up in my own thoughts
as neil would suggest
but either way
somewhere along the line it became the
16th chapel to me that didn't even make
sense to be the 16th
every time i think i've hit like the the
bedrock of my stupidity right somehow
something else comes along
um
anyways but since then
i have left italy sadly
i left italy
uh the food was [ __ ] unreal
and uh you know what killed me though
[ __ ] sorry i'm sorry about moving this
around here oh is that
is that my shirt making all that [ __ ]
noise i thought that was just in my ear
god damn it
how about now is that better now i can
move around there we go
i'm literally laying here with a [ __ ]
pad of paper under my recorder
this is so stupid i don't know i'm not
funny sitting down i gotta be laying
down or standing up all right i'm not
walking around for an hour and a half in
a [ __ ]
hotel room i can't believe all of that
had that scratch underneath it i thought
it was in the headphones
i thought there was a bug in there like
in star trek when they crawled into that
guy's [ __ ] ear remember they dropped
those little maggots in there that was
terrifying um anyways plowing ahead
so i leave italy and i fly up to uh
i'm on my way to glasgow so i have to
connect in amsterdam and as you fly up
i saw the entire
west coast of italy
it was insane and i just watched that
world war two documentary and i was
thinking of all that stuff you know
these soft underbelly
of the nazi europe when they came in
here and rather than going into this one
part they came in the southern part they
had to fight through the [ __ ]
mountains and that's all i'm thinking
and you look down from the air so much
of it like uh
it's really impressive like
even though i'm sure there's a zillion
people over there like how much of it is
still those green fields so when you
look down it looks like world war ii
um footage except now it's in full color
like i
have expected us to start dive bombing
and strafing some poor bastard trying to
run into the [ __ ]
tree line
and uh you fly over the swiss alps
and then right on up and uh was
just [ __ ] incredible i had my goddamn
face pressed up against the glass
like some eight-year-old on his first
trip i really have a geek for this
travel stuff man it's it's it's awesome
so
um
landed in amsterdam
get all the way up to glasgow connected
no [ __ ] problems
no nothing
and
people in scotland they're dead coolish
they're cool as hell
you show up
[ __ ] lady checking me and was going
to my show that night well there's a guy
checking me in but the other the other
lady who was working there you know most
countries you go into they're looking at
you like you're a [ __ ] terrorist
you know even though you look like ron
howard
they always go where are you staying i
don't [ __ ] know
what are you gonna call me
when i'm staying in a [ __ ] hotel how
long you here i'm here for a day oh
really
what are you only here for a day for oh
because i'm gonna blow the whole [ __ ]
place up what do you think what do you
think i'm here for
can't you see the sad clown in front of
you what do you think i'm doing here
i'm just as pasty as you you dumb [ __ ]
let me in your country right then i like
that
they don't like that at all over up in
scotland they don't give a [ __ ]
they're like oh that's that freckled
[ __ ] i'm gonna see tonight the [ __ ]
uh the [ __ ] shack down the street
so um
anyways went down
did the uh did the show work with this
hilarious guy gary little opened up for
me the guy was a [ __ ] riot
great guy and uh afterwards i hung out
with him and uh
kevin bridges
had a bunch of [ __ ]
you know
drank whiskey scotch whatever the [ __ ]
we were drinking just had a great night
talking comedy and all that type of
thing so uh i want to thank everyone who
came out to that show
it was just great man it was amazing
like seriously when i was on stage in
like scotland i didn't i didn't feel
like i was outside of the united states
except a couple times i said a couple of
dumb things but uh
you know they thought they would get
or whatever making [ __ ] baseball
references
stupid right so that one went great
next day kind of had a little bit of a
delayed flight flew down to amsterdam
that one was awesome had a bunch of
people
came in from germany and belgium
telling me i should do shows there so
maybe i'll add those the next time it
was just awesome and uh
actually spent an extra day
in amsterdam
and i was trying to be mature enough to
not go down sorry i gotta move this
[ __ ] thing i was trying to be mature
enough not to go down to the red light
district
you know
right across the street where i was
staying from was the vincent van gogh
museum so i'm like all right i'm going
to give a museum
another chance
because i get exac anxiety when i go
into museums because i go in there and
it's all this smart [ __ ] in there and i
could give a [ __ ] after the first
exhibit
like i literally just want to run
through the place and get out of there
and um
but i went to the vincent van gaal one
and i absolutely loved it
i loved it and for the first time i
think actually appreciated art
and i i hate to say this i think half of
the reason was i went by myself
there was nobody else there so i didn't
have to i'm always like 20 miles ahead
of anybody who i go to a museum with
you know those [ __ ] people you go to
museum with and they actually get the
[ __ ]
the headphones and the recorder and they
just go from exhibit to [ __ ] exhibit
they got to watch every goddamn film
and i i don't
i should respect people like that but i
don't i hate them so
anyways i went to the vincent van gogh
museum
it's insane
they just have his paintings hanging on
the [ __ ] wall
did that just sound dumb i don't know it
was always a zillion miles away to me
right so
i'm looking at them and as amazing as
they were i was still in and out of
there in 35 minutes and that includes
going to the gift shop
i walked in
and the first thing i saw was he drew a
picture of like he was taking this art
class and he had to draw like a picture
of like the skeleton or something like
that a painting
draw a picture paint the [ __ ] human
skeleton
so he painted it
and in the end he put a cigarette in its
mouth as like a [ __ ] you to his teacher
so immediately i like this guy
i like this guy he's not some goody two
shoes right you've got to do saying his
homework he's not that guy right
he's the guy who's gonna have the fake
id and go get you some booze in the
[ __ ] late 1880s
so i looked at all of his [ __ ] and i
really liked it there you go that's as
deep as i can say i didn't really like
his chalk period
he's painting with chalk or whatever the
black and white [ __ ] i wasn't into but
the thick paint with the lines i was
into that
it was great the further you step back
the more it looked like what the [ __ ] he
was painting then when he got up close
looked like a bunch of lines how do you
do that you know he can't stand
40 yards away with a long paintbrush
they didn't have that technology back in
the 1880s they didn't don't even tell me
they did
you know they look closely at his paint
he had a bunch of sand and leaves in it
that was out of his mind
the only thing i don't like is uh
he cut his air off i don't like that
part
you know
it's a dumb thing to cut your ear off
for although some people would say love
is the most important thing in life but
you know what it's not worth
yeah i don't know
turning yourself into marvin nash you
like mr blonde and marvin nash all at
the same time jesus christ is [ __ ]
horrific all right 17 minutes in let's
do uh let's do a little bit of
advertising here
um
all right
hang on a second hang on a second
you know i got a decent review on a show
i did over here in europe and someone
was trying to say that i pretend to be
stupid
and um
i just started laughing i was like if
that person ever heard me try to read
out loud
they would really retract that statement
i'm not saying i'm a [ __ ] but you know
come on 16 chapel
you're going to sign that up to your
[ __ ] spelling the spelling bee group
there or whatever man great everyone man
great i'm here to tell you about the man
great it's for men and it's [ __ ]
great
this holiday season think the man great
what is the man great you asked they are
100 made in america cast iron grilling
grates that are revolutionizing
revolutionizing the way people grill
named one of 2012's best grilling
accessories by men's health magazine
man's great man greats are the perfect
gift this holiday season click on the
man great banner at billboard.com for
the 1999 holiday special remember each
monday morning podcast order comes with
a heavy duty grilling brush again that's
the man great grill enhancement system
order today at billberg.com
all right that was only one [ __ ] up
that's not bad that's that's not bad
one over
all right
dollar shave club everyone you know the
deal for a couple bucks a month
dollarshaveclub.com delivers amazing
quality razors where right to your damn
door not only does it save you a ton of
cash it saves you from trudging to the
drugstore for a pack of blades
um personally i always get stuck behind
them you know i don't know some hipster
trying to buy some mustache trimmer i
don't know what the hell i'm trying to
say i just gotta skip past all this old
lady crap i don't get stuck behind them
you get stuck behind some jerk off you
don't want to be behind and you don't
need to be
why is that because with dollar shave
club for just a couple bucks a month
amazing quality razor blades are
delivered right to your door that's
right no more wasting time and no more
getting hit up for 20 bucks every time
you go to buy razors everybody here is
getting a dollar shave club blades
meaning me and you should too and here's
a genius idea absolute genius try
replacing your old shaving cream with dr
cavi's easy shave butter from
dollarshaveclub.com
trust me your face will thank you later
uh don't waste time at the drugstore
behind the lady paying in pennies go to
dollarshaveclub.com forward slash bar or
go to billboard.com and click on the
dollar shave club banner keep your
stress level low and your bank balance
high
shave time shave money go to
dollarshaveclub.com forward slash bill
burr
all right one more
elulu plus
mate hulu plus you've probably tried
hulu.com now with hulu plush you can
watch your favorite shows anytime
anywhere hulu plus let
hulu plus lets you watch thousands of
hit tv shows and a selection of
acclaimed movies on your television or
on the go with your smartphone or tablet
and it all streams in what hd for the
best viewing experience possible with
hulu plus you can watch your favorite
current tv shows like saturday night
live community and family guide you can
also you can also check out exclusive
content including hulu originals like
the awesome
starring snl seth meyers and moonboy
starring chris o'dowd from bridesmaids
hulu plus also offers a great selection
of acclaimed films for only 7.99 a month
you can stream as many tv shows and
movies as you want wherever you want
what more do you need i'll tell you what
right now
you can try hulu plus free for two weeks
when you go to hulu plus dot com slash
capital b i l
that's a special offer for my listeners
make sure you use the huluplus.com
so you get the extended free trial and
they know that we sent you once again go
to huluplus.com
bill now or click on the hulu plus
banner on the podcast page at
billboard.com
all right that wasn't too bad was it was
that sort of painless
how the [ __ ] did that take three minutes
um all right on back to the podcast here
um
what else did i want to talk about oh
when i was over in england i really saw
this crazy story
when i went to london yeah
they had a marine over there
a guy named alexander blackman
and he just got jailed for life for
murder
of an afghani insurgent
uh
it's unreal basically what happened was
i guess they shot this insurgent guy
and
this guy alexander blackman walked up to
him i gotta get the quote here
what exactly did he say
oh he just walked up to the insurgent as
the guy was laying there i guess wounded
and he he shot him in the chest and said
shuffle off this mortal coil
sorry shuffle off this mortal coil you
[ __ ]
it's nothing you wouldn't do to us
and for some reason the [ __ ] jerk off
behind him had a camera in his helmet
and they filmed it
so now britain has to act like they
don't care that he did that now they
have to act like they give a [ __ ] and
that that's conduct unbecoming of a good
[ __ ] soldier
uh if anybody can find a four second
moment in any
war in history where that that doesn't
happen
you know they're talking about how on
the other side when they catch these
guys
when they catch our guys they skin them
alive and cut their [ __ ] heads off
so as far as i'm concerned that guy got
off easy [ __ ] him am i the only guy
saving private ryan
what happened when they let that guy go
he came right back and started killing
their guys
you sent him over there
to kill the other guys
and evidently he didn't do it in the
proper [ __ ] way
uh you know
he saved the british people money you
don't have to feed that guy porridge
anymore
right
it's war
you're training these guys to murder
people
he goes out he does his [ __ ] job he
murders this guy
and now what now you gotta act like
you're outraged because it was filmed
that guy got [ __ ] over
he got [ __ ] over the same way the
49ers did when they played the saints
uh look
i am not i'm not pro-war i'm not but i'm
also not a [ __ ] [ __ ] okay you can't
train people to do some [ __ ] like that
and stick them
in those hellacious [ __ ] environments
where there really are no [ __ ] rules
regardless of whatever convention
geneva convention or whatever [ __ ]
that you signed give me a [ __ ] break
all right
i don't think what that guy did was i
don't even think
within the context of war
i mean morally is it right or wrong me
morally war isn't right
i don't understand
if he's actually was pinned down and he
[ __ ] shot that guy in the head they
give him they give him a medal
i know the whole thing is [ __ ] stupid
they
so the guy has to do at least 10 years
and uh personally speaking i hope they
send them to i was saying this on opi
anthony this morning i hope they send
that guy to the goodfellas jail
you know
don't don't put too many onions in the
sauce right okay now we can eat
all right you know it'd be great if
everybody around the world just quit
every army
that would be perfect then you just let
these [ __ ] nerds with their ties
right and their beards and [ __ ] just let
them have it out right there's a [ __ ]
hacky thought
am i writing the lyrics to a hippie song
all the leaves are proud
sorry
oh [ __ ]
oh my god this [ __ ] tour this tour is
gonna be the death of me man
i swear to god no it isn't i'm gonna
tough tough my way through it because i
just read the [ __ ] new bobby orr book
highly recommend it highly recommend it
i'm thinking of everything he said in
that book and it's keeping me going i'm
just focusing on tonight's game here in
dublin
i'm not thinking about how i have to
[ __ ] connect an a frau one more
[ __ ] time
all the way over to goddamn helsinki i'm
not thinking about that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] flight might as well be 20 years
in the future
that's [ __ ] i wish i wish i believed
in that
um anyways what else
well i guess i just brought up nfl
football i did not watch a second of it
yesterday i'm on the other side of the
planet and uh
i don't know what i was doing was trying
not to get sick i guess i've been eating
like [ __ ] and uh
although i did get some i got some
friendly emails from some cleveland
brown fans
notifying me that the patriots won
um
here's one hey you red-haired [ __ ]
uh haven't you guys exhausted the red
haired angle there's so many other
things about me that are stupid looking
that you could make fun of you know
jesus christ enough with the [ __ ] i get
it hey there red balls how many [ __ ]
times
you know i got a gigantic forehead you
know i'm not gonna help you guys out you
figure it out
you one-trick ponies
all right hey red hey you redhead [ __ ]
i hope you're proud of the patriots win
nothing like cheating all day to get
what you want tom brady's a [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh god i don't understand how people
watch nfl football every week and they
don't see what's going on
and they start blaming the other team
you know
didn't you see when the patriots played
the [ __ ] uh
who the hell did we play there the end
of the game can't even remember we
played that [ __ ] game in the end of
the game uh
they didn't call the interference i mean
it happens to everybody
no the [ __ ] league loves going brady
you can you [ __ ] these patients fear
it's called the [ __ ] [ __ ] it's
it's happening to everybody
all right you stupid [ __ ] browns fan
did you notice that the nfl settled out
of court
did you notice that that they settled
out of [ __ ] court
to those those [ __ ] those hits do you
understand that you understand that
they're all about making money
okay
if drew brees is out if tom brady is out
if peyton manning is out they lose
[ __ ] money
so they are ridiculously protecting all
of those quarterbacks and like in all
sports the stars will get even more
calls
all right you dumb brown [ __ ]
okay and as far as the past interference
calls if you're mad at that don't get
mad at the patriots
get get mad at jim irsay and peyton
manning who [ __ ] moan and complain and
and [ __ ] her say spearheaded
changing the rules of coverage you
combine that with the fact that the nfl
has hit their saturation point
where
there's no more sports fans left
to watch the nfl so now they have to get
people the casual fan the person who
doesn't give a [ __ ] okay if you don't
give a [ __ ] about the sports the sport
that you know is on in the background
the way to get people's heads to turn is
scoring
so everything is about scoring now
okay that past interference call when i
was growing up was called coverage that
was great coverage two years ago
or a year ago you know
maybe two and a half years ago that was
great coverage now that's considered
past interference it's absolutely
[ __ ] ridiculous
it's a travesty i've said every week on
this [ __ ] podcast that it used to be
the hardest thing to do in in in
professional sports in america anyways
is to hit the curveball now it is trying
to cover a [ __ ] receiver
all right
you can't
it you can't hit him anymore you can't
touch him you can basically run next to
him but i think you have to hold your
breath because you're not even allowed
to breathe on with this [ __ ] point
and now they got this thing you know you
can no helmet to helmet so now they hit
low and now guys like gronkowski just
got his knee blown out because the other
guy in on cleveland like a two year two
years ago that would have been a dirty
hit why did he hit him so low now
because of that settled out of suit
thing you can't
you know helmet the helmet uh
said all that court thing i can't
[ __ ] talk i'm so jet-lagged
they gotta go low
and all you [ __ ] [ __ ] on the
internet who's sitting there saying that
gronkowski's made out of glass that's
just so really
you could take a defensive back
going full speed into the side of your
knee you could handle that
you fat [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm glad your
dreams didn't come true how do you like
that that's right i came with no gloves
no gloves on go [ __ ] yourselves um
i can't even speak this [ __ ] week
what else did i see uh
rose bowl tailgate legend
an awesome [ __ ] comedian uh joe
bartnick asked me if i saw the bruins
penguins game so i actually watched some
of the highlights of that
and uh
you know that was very out of the uh out
of character
by uh sean thornton i don't obviously
don't condone that i don't think he does
either i don't know why he did that
you know i know marshawn just got hit
marchand however the [ __ ] he's supposed
to say it now
uh
but yeah i don't condone that either
although i did find it funny all the
penguins fans not joe but the other ones
talking about dirty hits you know as
they look the other way with the
absolute [ __ ]
just some of the filthiest [ __ ]
people ever have played for the penguins
and they just looked the other way you
know
matt cook of samuelson all of those guys
the amount of [ __ ] careers those
[ __ ] ended
and none of the penguins fans had any
problem with it they got off samuelson
in their ring of honor
now they get a [ __ ] about sean thornton
you know
the [ __ ] uh but haven't said that i
don't condone whether it happens to my
team or my team's doing it that's that's
that's dirty play
you know and he should be punished
um but i mean that's the only time i've
ever seen him do something like that now
if he does it again then he's a dirty
piece of [ __ ] which i know he's not
gonna
all right
um all right
with that what else can i talk about
what should i do here overseas sports i
went to a
premier game premier football league
game yesterday i went to arsenal
first everton and i guess arsenal was
heavily favored
and uh it was an incredible experience
it really was the um
the i guess the club itself i guess you
would call it
uh i don't like naming names
on the podcast but uh they hooked me up
with tickets through the promoter and um
we sat basically in the best seats in
the house like the club seats
the leather seats they gave me a little
blankie for it went out there in case i
got cold i took a picture of it with the
hashtag cozy smug [ __ ] and i went out
there and it was it was great
listen to everybody singing the songs
and [ __ ] but if if i lived in england i
would definitely pick a team
and i would go to the pub and learn all
the songs and then i would go sit in the
upper deck
because who wouldn't want to get
shit-faced standing up the whole game
singing songs it looked great so anyways
it was 0-0 or nil-nil the exact [ __ ]
reason why americans do not watch soccer
or football whatever the [ __ ] you want
to call it
and then finally but it was still a
beautiful [ __ ] game to watch
it really is it's a lot like hockey to
be honest with you except that's
you know it's on grass
long story short arsenal finally [ __ ]
scores
and the whole stadium breaks into this
song about arsenal uh i don't know they
haven't got i guess back in the day they
used to always win one to nothing
they go they score one goal and then
like a bunch of [ __ ] they just would
all go back on defense and you couldn't
score on them as the whole crowd would
sing this song you know one nothing
arsenal and you you know you're gonna
[ __ ] lose and all this [ __ ] so
anyways
so they go up one nothing with like two
minutes left and they all start singing
the song the whole [ __ ] stadium
except for this one little corner that
was for uh everton
and they get their into the second verse
the whole place is singing they got
their scarves out holding up going nuts
big glowing fish and chips looks on
their faces having a hell of a [ __ ]
time and when they're in the middle of
the second verse everton scored
oh did it take the wind out of their
[ __ ] sails
they went so the everton people are
going [ __ ] insane
somebody lit off like a little smoke
bomb that had this blue smoke that was
the cover of everton i guess you're not
supposed to do it the cops all came
running over
and uh
i don't know they just told them to
knock it off
in america they would have dragged like
two rows out beating them with clubs
but uh
and then all the blue smoke just kind of
went all over this one part of the
stadium
and that's how it ended
one to one and i had a great [ __ ]
time and uh i highly suggest it
if you highly recommend it if you come
over to england you definitely got to go
uh you got to go to one of those one of
those games premier league games it was
[ __ ] tremendous
and i plan on going to many more and uh
hopefully in the future but uh this is
something that i found out that was
interesting was um
all the maniacs go to the soccer games
and the rich [ __ ] go to rugby
who would have thought right
of the posh [ __ ] as they call them go
to rugby i guess in england that makes
no sense to me
who would think that rugby would be like
is it like an elitist sport
i get that i was even talking to the cab
driver this morning as i'm going
in ireland he was going yeah a lot of
people they go in to become doctors and
something like that's like those guys do
i don't [ __ ] know is this is this
even remotely [ __ ] entertaining i
have no idea
i've been on a plane every [ __ ] day
for the last four days so i don't know
uh
what else how far into this podcast now
is it time for the yeah there we go not
yet not yet oh jesus christ robinson no
robinson cano got traded being traded he
signed with the seattle [ __ ] mariners
for more money
why would why would you do that
why would you go for playing second base
with the new york yankees
he's going to get 190 million dollars no
240 million i'm gonna go play for the
seattle [ __ ] mariners
and what the [ __ ] are the seattle
mariners thinking giving up all that
goddamn money didn't they learn anything
from the texas rangers
giving a 200 million dollar contract to
a [ __ ] shortstop you're gonna give a
240 million dollar contract to a second
baseman
you know i didn't rub it in with paul
version i know he's [ __ ] devastated
he was trying to say i'm not mad at him
you know he's got to take the money it's
a difference of 50 million dollars i get
it i get it
i mean you get it that is a total slap
in the face of the new york yankees
that's not supposed to happen to the
yankees
you know
i don't know good on the yankees [ __ ]
him don't pay him all that [ __ ] 190
million dollars and he leaves go ahead
leave
go out to seattle have a good time
losing
robbie
um yeah i don't think he's gonna do [ __ ]
out there although seattle's talking a
bunch of [ __ ]
you know they're saying well we're not
done yet we're going to overpay for even
more people
um see what the yankees created and then
the red sox supported
[Laughter]
oh by the way big congratulations to the
seattle seahawks fans for once again
screaming mindlessly
at a crowd screamer meter whatever the
[ __ ] you're doing out there uh
congratulations on the plaque that was
awarded to you that you'll probably have
for like another two weeks before
somebody else decides they're gonna
break the record
has any crowd failed yet
when they've set their minds to
screaming for the sake of [ __ ]
screaming you know some a lot of
seahawks fans think that i'm [ __ ] on
their team i'm not i have money on you
[ __ ]
to win the super bowl
in fact if you guys do not win the super
bowl this year i feel it's a monumental
failure because i don't see anybody else
in your way
who's in your way
nobody it's yours to [ __ ] lose
you got the best goddamn defense in the
nfl defense wins championships you think
you can't handle peyton manning
huh
and that [ __ ] hat box head of his
actually you got to be wearing a top hat
you could put a top hat on his head and
it would like you could just pull it all
the way down the brim would be resting
on his shoulders
so what does that mean billy's not a
good quarterback no it doesn't it
doesn't mean he's not a good quarter
that's a hell of a point you just made
i can i really just for one week just
not [ __ ] on peyton manning
um anyways i think you guys are going to
win it but that stupid loudest crowd
thing
i swear to god and i and in my heart of
hearts i know this that real seattle
seahawks fans when they're at the game
they don't participate
i know they don't the same way when i go
to a red sox game i don't sing sweet
caroline i don't buy the pink hats i
don't buy any of that horseshit i don't
even wear red socks [ __ ] now when i go
to a [ __ ] game
it's gotten so ridiculous so
that stupid loudest crowd
record what it should be done is
secretly
they should be recording crowds if you
really want to figure out which one is
the loudest
if you're going to throw out the
acoustics of the building inside versus
outside versus stadiums deliberately
designed to be louder
um
because if you tell everybody they're
coming down there with those [ __ ]
bull horns
all right
hey seattle fans [ __ ] grow up
okay
keep your eye on the prize
don't blow out your voices you're gonna
win the super bowl this year okay then
you can scream and yell then what are
you gonna do
try to break your own record and give
yourself another [ __ ] plaque
oh everybody gets a ribbon
um all right that's my little [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] for this week uh what
do we got here
let's continue on with some uh some
emails for this week
ah [ __ ] am i getting a cold ah jesus
christ uh little fact for the podcast
hello bill how are you doing uh i was at
your show in amsterdam last week and it
was a great show hope you enjoyed your
time in holland i did i had a great time
oh i didn't mention i i tried not to go
down to the red light district but i had
to do it
you know how do you not look at hookers
and windows
it's unreal
so i went down there by myself like a
total [ __ ] creep
and uh
i looked at him
[Laughter]
and it's uh it's fascinating and sad and
all of that and i actually saw one guy
walking out when i was across the street
and [ __ ] and it's just like that guy
just [ __ ] a woman paid money and
[ __ ] her
it's just the most bizarre thing ever
but they're uh they're really good
looking
you know
as far as like a woman you got there was
one unbelievable
[ __ ] gorgeous woman and she was so
good-looking she wasn't even looking out
her window she was just sitting at her
little desk
you know just like look you know you
want to [ __ ] me
look take your money out and knock on
the door but i'm not gonna stand here
at the [ __ ] window all right this
[ __ ] recorder keeps moving around
here um
and i also saw a skating rink when i was
out there and they were playing this
[ __ ] insane music
as they were skating around
almost like this poker music
i got to upload the video i swear to god
all of that [ __ ] just sounds like hitler
youth music to me i don't know why
let me see if i can play some of this
for you i'm trying to find this video i
sent it to everybody i knew
called it hitler on ice hope you can
hear this
[Applause]
[Music]
so this shit's going on as people are
skating around i just came upon this
walking by myself in amsterdam
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh god sorry
anyways uh let's get on with this thing
uh sinch
where are we anyhow i wasn't sure if
you're being sarcastic when you stated
holland didn't have slavery i wasn't i
didn't think you had
i didn't think you guys had slavery and
a bunch of people corrected me
oh that's right because i was in all
right let me set this up right before i
read this email
basically i was in holland on december
5th
and that was uh
i guess that's santa claus birthday
not in holland i guess just officially
that is santa claus's birthday santa
claus was a legend that allegedly
jesus bill allegedly a real person
they don't know when he lived and all
that it's very jesus-like but allegedly
he's a real [ __ ] guy
december 5th is when he was born and
they celebrate by dressing up like santa
claus and essentially putting on
blackface
but it's supposed to represent he's gone
down every chimney in the city so he's
got soot all over his face
you know and his nia was saying so
wouldn't it be sort of streaked rather
than put all over their [ __ ] face
it's blackface so
i was asking them about it going well
you guys not doing it in like an
offensive way i mean you guys didn't
have slavery right and they had this
they had this big laugh
and i thought that
oh no they all went like no no no no and
i thought they meant like no no no we're
so against slavery don't put that [ __ ]
on me i guess uh
i guess i was wrong so here we go here
are the facts uh he goes since you are
like me most of the time pretty informed
it could be that nobody told you that
ships from holland transported about
half a million slaves during the
transatlantic slave trade in the 17th
century i checked this [ __ ] out at
wikipedia so it must be valid that's
hilarious he goes actually the slave
trade was one of the reasons that
holland flourished in the golden age as
we call it so yeah we did play a role in
this not really part of our history
we're proud of
uh you might ask yourself why i wrote
uh to tell you this it's because i'm a
[ __ ] that likes to tell people they are
wrong i don't think you're a [ __ ] i
think that's great that you informed me
of that um so
so there you go
alrighty then
well why would they go up like that well
i guess because they couldn't make it
diagonally across from africa right
although if you go straight across you
kind of
where are you at this point
if you went straight across you'd be
like in aruba
maybe north of that i don't [ __ ] know
cozumel
ah bill you know
do you have to reinforce every three
minutes how dumb you are on this podcast
i'll [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you with you with your brain
um
oh this is a reply to that 22 dating 16
year old
um oh no it isn't is it nor is it a
reply to it
anyways a few weeks ago somebody wrote
it was saying that my uh same way he was
or whatever i forget how [ __ ] old he
was all i know is his 16 year old sister
was dating a 22 year old
what should he do
um so i think somebody's responding to
that i'm guessing because it says re 22
dating 16.
um okay my dad started dating my mom
when he was 22 and she was 15.
gross
his dad told him
he could get in trouble and advised him
to stop
my dad told him no it is legal as the
age of consent is 14 or something here
yeah you know when you're [ __ ]
somebody that that young you probably
want to be a little more specific
no it is in the legal age is like 14 or
something
14 16
split the difference she's 15 and then
you're [ __ ] arrested
he said anyways he said uh they ended
agreeing uh they ended up agreeing to go
ask a lawyer
uh whoever was wrong had to pay my
grandpa paid the lawyer fees and my
parents have now been married for almost
30 years
but if some 22 year old wanted to date
my 15 year old daughter i wouldn't have
it yeah absolutely
absolutely
i don't think that that's a great thing
that your parents stayed together like
that
did your mom even get to see what was
out there before she ended up with your
dad
jesus christ
first restaurant she walks into she's
just like this is the best food ever
it's never going to get any better than
this
i guess that's good for you right so you
don't feel like your mom's a [ __ ]
but why would she be a [ __ ]
why can't she go out
and do what guys do i'll tell you why
because when we do it it takes skill
i mentioned that before in this podcast
a guy getting laid that's a skill
all right a woman getting laid it's just
gluttonous behavior it's not even this
you know
where is the challenge
there is none
you can go down the [ __ ] bar right
now and have a entire bar on one if you
wanted to
right
like what is impressive as a woman you
know for a guy if you get a two on one
that's like you know the [ __ ] brass
ring
what is impressive for a woman what do
you have like a 15 on one
and what is impressive about it that you
could [ __ ] physically take it
oh jesus bill that was just wow that was
a whole nother level of ignorance all
right let's let's plow let's just plow
ahead after that [ __ ] one 48 minutes
in hey uh billy red
billy red coppola
francis ford coppola billy red coppola
all right i'll go with that
uh are you going to check out any
foreign films while you're overseas dude
i can't even read advertising
you think i want to [ __ ] watch a film
having to look up and down like i'm
[ __ ] texting while driving do you
really think i want to do that listening
to my stuttering voice in my head
are you going to check any out any
foreign films while overseas i suggest
you do it's a trip seeing the cultural
differences i lived in london in france
and would check them out from time to
time in case you don't make it here's
what you're missing
uh tits
uh
derivative benny hill style slapstick
derivative monty python dryness
derivative theater drama
the occasional dick and more tits
some of it's great though so maybe
you'll get lucky
i don't know what any of that means i
guess there's a lot of tits occasionally
show somebody's dick and they do a lot
of monty python benny hill type humor
well i've already seen the originals you
know why the [ __ ] would i want to go see
that they got to have something better
than that don't they
one of those fancy films that comes out
at cairns is it khan film festival wrath
of khan
uh
all right bill where's lenny bruce bill
i'm not a stand-up comic
i'm not even a huge comic geek i am
however a freedom of speech geek and
comedians are the most important people
when it comes to this so why aren't
comics who for the most part operate
independently louder about what's going
on
i just read about a blog by a girl
bashing kurt uh metzger
i don't oh he's [ __ ] hilarious
uh he goes uh i didn't know who he was
but i looked him up and he's really
funny he makes good points about that
stuff the blogger just completely labels
him
uh completely labels him things he's not
just because she can't understand his
context you are outspoken about this and
have been honest when asked
but why aren't people louder
dude you're speaking very vaguely louder
about what bloggers bitching about
comedy
or bitching about social issues because
i don't mean to single out so and so or
so and so but they're in big positions
to speak out against the stifling of the
art doesn't anyone want to go down as
the guy who stepped up and articulated
what they believe
it doesn't have to be malicious but with
some charts and graphs you could explain
it to people like that blogger
jim norton debated i was just going to
bring jim norton up yeah
that they're missing the point
um
well you know there is also you you kind
of hope it just goes away
if you talk about it then they get like
more hits it's really just like
lazy reporting
um
i saw when jim debated that blogger
on kamau show uh what the hell was it
called they're uh
totally biased
and uh
you know
i thought she was you know for all the
ignorance that she was
talking about like the general terms
with which she defined stand-up comedy
and comedians and all that like
and especially talk about how angry
comics were i thought it was really
ironic that she was sort of the epitome
of all of that
she seemed very angry she spoke very
generally about stand up and really had
no idea what she was talking about
and um
i thought i said that did i say that on
the [ __ ] podcast i don't i don't give
a [ __ ] about
look if somebody wants to go to a comedy
club i've said this before if they want
to go to a comedy club and take a
comedian seriously
they are well within their right to do
that but just because they decide
to take a comic seriously does not mean
that that comic
now
like meant
what they said in the joke it doesn't
make the joke not a joke anymore just
because someone decided to take it
seriously so
um
i can only speak for myself the reason
why i don't talk about it because
i think it's silly
considering all the other [ __ ] that's
going on and then also to sit there and
act like
i can't remember the last time i heard a
rape joke like just sit there and act
like that's what's going on
i mean i i don't i don't [ __ ] it i
thought i've already talked about this
so uh
you know
where's lenny bruce that's the name of
your thing that's a lenny bruce moment
to [ __ ] say that i mean i guess what
you're saying with the freedom of speech
but
the bloggers have freedom of speech they
have the freedom to uh
get pissed off about it and uh
i don't know if anything they're
probably helping comedy
maybe a lot of rapists wouldn't come
down to the comedy clubs because they
didn't think that there'd be any humor
for them
you know and it's just nice to know
that there's enough comics out there
that have the brilliance to understand
that rapists before they're caught
you know they like to laugh too
so there you go everybody makes out
all right accidentally dating a high
school chick
dear bill
wait a minute accidentally dating a high
school chick all right it can happen
she's super hot you're so psyched she's
just gonna blow you
you know she looks older than her years
i'm already making excuses for this guy
uh i'm a 24 year old expatriate
australian that now lives in europe it's
every bit the sexual buffet
that teen titty comedies of the 80s
promised all right this is already
getting creepy because you said
accidentally
dating a a
a high school chick and you just used
the word teen
okay
does not seem so doesn't seem so
accidental one sentence in
please don't be creepy
and continuing however i've recently
started dating a certain lady
and she's that in every sense of the
word smart as a whip caustic as hell and
yet warm when you're both alone together
so here's the back story i've been here
a few weeks i arrive at this at this
house buddy
i don't even make it past the front hall
and i meet this girl everything goes
great we hook up and we've been dating
for a few weeks fast forward a bit and
she breaks off plans casually mentioning
that she has to study for her
he writes it in this other language the
rough equivalent to the american s.a.t
sats now don't get me wrong the subject
of school has come up
example what subject was she interested
in etc etc however this is where the
language barrier can be a bit of a [ __ ]
the germans and the french can also
refer university as school and i
naturally assumed she meant university
back home we graduated 16 to 17 years
old uh oh oh oh gee
so to bring this thing full circle i'm
wondering what uh i'm wondering do i
bring it off break it off with this
chick
wait dude you didn't even see how old
she was
the germans and the french also referred
to university of school
and i naturally assumed she meant
university
back home we graduated 16 to 17 years
old so how old is she
uh what are you doing dude you don't
tell me how old she is
all right i'll continue here so to bring
in things full circle i'm wondering do i
break it off with this chick
which i think
can be a dick move given that we've
already
had enough explorative sex to make hbo
look like dora the explorer and to leave
her now would look like i've been
leading her on slash using her or do i
stay with her and risk our relationship
becoming strained by the different
cultural gap for example uh for example
she's dealing with the high school [ __ ]
that i've long since resolved myself
the essentials i like this girl a lot
we've got a lot in common literature
arts sports booze and she doesn't find
the fact
that i collect pre-70s playboy's creepy
a huge [ __ ] plus given the woman i've
dated oh dude what the f
when did i start attracting like sex
offenders so you have this weird
collection of porn you're not telling me
how old she is
the cons she's in high school still
lives with their parents and is french
they can be temperamental as [ __ ] dude
how old are you
oh he's 24.
what is the age of consent and how old
is she
i don't know what you're saying here sir
how old is she
i'm not commenting on that dude i need i
need numbers
uh
right right back dude
right back let me know how old you are
because i don't know what the [ __ ]
you're asking me there
um anyways
is that oh i got to do the other half of
the [ __ ] uh
goddamn reads here
little maybe i'll tell you a quick
little story or something for your
bedtime there all right e-voice everyone
the holidays are coming
and as a business owner you know what
this means absolute crickets face it the
next couple of months are the calm
before the storm now is the time to do
something that will dramatically help
your 2014. what is it evoice e-voice is
a simple technology that helps you to
make more money with e-voice
e-voices toll-free or local numbers call
routing tools in a professional dial by
name directory your business will look
like a million bucks and with e-voice if
you can take a call they will transcribe
the voicemail and they'll email it to
you you'll never be caught off guard
again e-voice has been saving companies
thousands of dollars every month making
them more efficient more productive
there is no quicker or easy way to
transform your business for 2014 and
with evoice you can try it before you
buy it right now you can get a 30 day
free trial to e-voice when you go to
evoice.com billboard or go to
billboard.com and click on the e-voice
banner the evoice.com bill that's evoice
dot com slash billboard or billboard.com
and click on the e-voice banner
um
okay stamps.com
and yes i realized i just mispronounced
my name stamps.com with the holidays
almost here
you don't have time to go to the post
office traffic parking it will be packed
with everyone mailing holiday gifts and
packages so what to do use stamps.com
instead with stamps.com you can avoid
all the hassle man i'm going to the post
office during the busy holiday season
everything you would do at the post
office you could do it right from your
desk buy and print official u.s postage
using your own computer or printer print
postage for any letter or package the
instance the instant you need it and
then the mailman comes by and picks it
up so easy so convenient doesn't get any
better i use stamps.com to send out all
my t-shirts and my dvds i'm a [ __ ] if i
can figure it out you can too right now
get this special offer when you use my
last name bur burr for a no risk trial
plus 110 bonus
offer that includes a digital scale and
up to 55 dollars free postage come on
man you can't beat this deal don't wait
go to stamps.com right now before you do
anything else you click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type in bur that's stamps.com enter
bur
and last but not least
this might be my the favorite name of
anything i've ever advertised here
other than one white charlie's uh
sherry's berries
it says insert story when you've given
or received
uh
the gifts
well i i've been out of town i haven't
gotten sherry's berries yet ever all
right sherry's berries since the end of
the year is all about delicious holiday
food
why not send an extra special holiday
treat to friends family business
associates
associates everyone you know i've never
met a person who didn't love sherry's
berries
send giant dipped strawberries from
sherry's berries for only 19.99 that's
over a 40 percent savings go to
barrys.com click on the microphone and
type in bur burr for my listeners
double the berries
for just ten dollars more
berries are terrific and a sweet holiday
gift
they also have delicious products such
as christmas cake pops cheesecakes and
dipped pretzels
here's the only way to get
this special 1999 sherry's berries offer
call 866 fruit
i'm sorry
what the [ __ ] am i selling
did i approve this this is [ __ ]
ridiculous
who the [ __ ] is gonna buy this [ __ ] this
is the funniest [ __ ] i've ever seen in
my [ __ ] life
christmas cake pops cheesecakes and
dipped pretzels
call 866 fruit everybody
ate some sorry 866 fruit 0-2
or even better
visit berries.com
oh punch drunk
oh please spell out the words oh by all
means berries
b-e-r-r-i-e-s
berries
click on the microphone on the top right
corner and type in burr
you gotta see these enormous berries for
yourself
go i swear to god this is the copy go to
berries.com click on the microphone and
tip in burr
type in bur dip your balls and dip your
berries in that don't wait now order
order some chocolate berries for the
[ __ ] person in your life
oh [ __ ] i needed that that was wonderful
i'm sure i'll get some complaints on
that one we need a conference call can't
do it i'm in helsinki
all right wrap it up here we go
now that the show is over wait a minute
i can't wrap it up this quick i'll do
i'll do the wrap up then i'll tell you
another story here uh wrap up here we go
now that the show is over
don't forget to sign up for your free
trial of hulu plus hulu plus lets you
binge on thousands of hit shows anytime
anywhere on your tv pc smartphone or
tablet support this podcast and get an
extended free trial of hulu plus when
you go to the podcast page at
billbert.com and click on the hulu plus
banner
or go to huluplus.com
bill that's huluplus.com bill
hey you [ __ ] better buy some sherry's
berries because i'm going to get in
trouble with that [ __ ] reed and i'm
not changing it because that was
hilarious
um
uh
wiping tears away here
um
ah what does it say um so anyways the
tour continues tonight i'm in dublin
and uh
i got this show at the vic theater
and then where do i go the whole rest of
the weekend just
traveling here i got helsinki tuesday
copenhagen
on uh
[ __ ] copenhagen
wednesday
is that right
helsinki copenhagen then oslo thursday
and then stockholm
friday and then i fly to iceland
for the last one and uh i've been having
some unbelievable shows i gotta tell you
something man i
that london thing you know i already
know i already gave glasgow and uh
and um
jesus christ
amsterdam
[ __ ] punch drunk here like uh
i'm those amazing great crowds and
everything and then london just as far
as like just all the american comics
that have come over and uh
gotten their breaks in london
you know from the bill hicks's to uh
patrice o'neill
and um
i don't know that was really definitely
a special that was one of those
weekends as i i was doing it i was i was
like really nervous before the shows and
[ __ ] like
um i did not i'm not taking any of this
trip lightly and this has been an
amazing
just an amazing thing man to be able to
go all through europe here and uh
i know i'm only here for like a day and
that type of stuff but uh this is the
beginning of many many many tours for me
over here
and uh i'm hopefully gonna be saying the
same thing about australia i know i got
canada coming up in march
and uh i just want to thank everybody
who's been coming out to the shows and
i've had a bunch of stand-up comics
overseas coming up to me and that's like
the biggest compliment you can get
people uh comics coming out to your
shows and coming up and saying that they
actually like what you do so it's really
cool and uh met a bunch of cool fans too
um
i had a couple people where the hell was
i someone night in london
somebody actually got me a cigar which
is great please don't bring me any more
cigars because i'm trying to cut down on
that habit but i gotta thank this dude
jimmy came and gave me a cigar
uh
it's just been great meeting the fans
and that type of stuff and people
getting the dvds and [ __ ] so uh so
really nothing funny i just wanna i'm
only halfway through this tap way
tonight i just want to thank everybody
who came out and uh
it's been great
and uh that's it there you go ended up
nicely
and i my apologies to barrys.com i
didn't i didn't look at the copy before
i read that this
i'm too [ __ ] immature to read [ __ ]
like that i'm sure you have wonderful
chocolate covered berries
all right
all right you [ __ ]
go [ __ ] yourselves i'll talk to you next
week